gods a dark character you know he is a
very complicated schizophrenia Colin is
an addict basically and that was how I
originally were you know found my way
into the role that he was completely
craving and lustful and powerless in in
the thrall of this of this very very
very potent drug that possesses him to
have that kind of Oh Liam again and to
get inside of it was was quite strange
and took me by surprise so the very
first day principal photography was it
was the seminal scene between Colin and
Bilbo Baggins was also Martin Freeman's
first day as Bilbo Baggins
why don't lead the team of riddles very
focused and intense kind of scenes to
come up with we plays the whole thing up
from beginning to end it's like a 13
minute scene we did it again and again
and again for two weeks and it really
gave us a chance to finally be there and
to experiment with it
lots of different ideas and so it's a
really really fantastic way of working
technologically the whole world of
performance capture has moved on now we
can shoot on live action sets at the
same time there's no disconnect whereas
on the Lord of the Rings
I played out all the scenes with with it
with Elijah Wood and Sean Astin but then
I had to go and shoot them again on the
motion capture stage separately it is
still in its infancy in terms of works
on the go and the ability that it gives
an actor to transform whilst retaining a
real emotional to the truth so no matter
how big or wacky or abstract or the
design of the character it still is
always rooted in this emotional truthful
actors performance you have a terror to
term when you come back